if you could he could do it both lay  with you it's just it's a hugely the  books and easy popular I think it was a  very risky thing it's a mixture of  things I think it's the fun it's rooted  so much in in history and they're sort  of but all the stuff we love about you  know our own history it's very like that  it's about power struggles and paternal  rivalry and then Dragons so it's kind of  but everything where do you think the  cuts off is there a cut-off point where  is too far the moment that I have sex it  could go on through a decade would you  be up for that well I mean I know I was  I was in one episode last year so this  year it's vital for me it's not exactly  a retirement plan sorry it's like you  know the really big shows you know mash  and phrase friends and those Americans  that decade-long shows so I suppose it  depends on how long georgeanna Dan and  David want to carry on I mean there's  obviously a huge about material